thank you thanks for the kind invitation
and thank you all for being here so I'm
gonna tell you a brief summary of some
of our recent and continuing work on
developing a an axiomatic theory of four
of non-bayesian and Bayesian social
learning in networks this is basically
the idea of trying to figure out how
people in groups make decisions based on
their private observations and opinions
of others this is joint work with my
former students who Yama la vie and Ali
Riza Saleh he and I mean Rahimi on so
there's a lot of evidence that suggests
that opinions of individuals in in
networks are often influenced by their
private observations and opinions of
friends neighbors and and others and
there's a sort of been a continuing
theme of research across multiple
disciplines and trying to figure out how
individuals combine their private
observations and opinions of their peers
when these observations are not shared
but it's only the opinions that are
shared whether it's in making political
decisions on which candidate to vote for
or in trying to decide you know based on
reviews which theater to go to or which
restaurant to go to so this has led to a
basically a long-standing set of
questions in how should individuals
combine their own observations and and
and views and opinions and as I said
there's a long history in in discussing
these types of topics across multiple
disciplines in fact if you go through
the basics of decision theory going back
to all the way to 1950s you see traces
of this question to the work of all men
in our community to the series of papers
by
Borkar and Mariah in economics the work
of Galen Karev and later Rosenberg and
others the work of Ilan Doble was
declaran Daron Acemoglu and some of our
work and work of Elkin on muscle and
omerta Moo's they've been trying to sort
of investigate how rational individuals
in in in groups make decisions based on
opinions of others or actions of others
and and their private observations
there's also a parallel line of
literature in which the argument is that
you know rational updating of opinions
as evidenced by some experimental
results in behavioral economics
literature is it's too hard and
therefore people use rule of thumb and
heuristic rules for for updating their
their decisions and these two camps have
sort of evolved somewhat independently
there's a long history for for both of
them and of course one canonical model
that has been used quite a bit across
multiple communities it's sort of the
consensus based on averaging model or
the de Groote model which goes back to
early 70s has its origins in in the work
of stone in in late 50s I believe and
the idea is that if you think of
opinions as a sort of probabilistic
vector think of you know you have
multiple decisions you create a
probability vector which tells you your
affinity to each or your belief in in
each of the possible States and one way
to aggregate these opinions is for
individuals in a network to repeatedly
average these and eventually hopefully
if the network is connected to reach a
sort of a type of a consensus and
there's a large literature in in
statistics going back to 1980s that
built a build on this work and tries to
figure out what are the right ways of
aggregating or fusing different
probabilistic opinions or beliefs is
averaging the right thing is are other
functions that one needs to use to
average and so there's a lot of
literature on on trying to figure this
out
and actually the the it's amazing how
diverse the set of communities that have
looked at this problem is you know if
you go back to like I said we're a
decision theory and statistics that's
sort of natural also economics but you
also see this in political science and
and in economics where there's a lots
and lots of literature in trying to
figure out what's the right way to fuse
probabilistic opinions and of course in
in viewing how one does this in a
network setting the natural question to
ask is well what how do you do this when
you have a single agent in that that the
sort of the rational benchmark is to use
a repeated application of Bayes rule as
a way to update opinions the idea is
that you start with some probabilistic
model which is sort of your your
likelihood function you have a prior you
get the observation and then you compute
your posterior according to Bayes rule
which we know from undergraduate
probability now if you have a stream of
observations that are iid you can use
these observations to deform your prior
overtime and then you get this type of a
of an update with with a normalizer you
could see that the update is log-linear
in in your previous beliefs and we sort
of know the conditions under which the
beliefs converge we know even you know
from Journal Stein lemma that the
convergence is exponentially fast if the
states are separable according to the KL
distances between likelihoods defined at
different states so basically the idea
is you have the prior you have a
likelihood you have the observation you
have this normalizer which is the
probability of observation and you keep
repeatedly you can do this and this is
sort of the benchmark of rational
decision making and the question of
course that we want to ask is how does
one generalize this to a network setting
and many people of course have have
looked at this both on the statistics
side on the economic side and and so
forth and experimental evidence suggests
that this is actually a hard thing to do
and the
amount of calculations that you need to
do to do this Bayesian benchmark in a
network setting is sort of beyond the
cognitive ability of individuals and the
reason is that you don't have access to
other people's observation you are
seeing their beliefs but their beliefs
are influenced by their own observations
and the belief of their neighbors which
is influenced by their own observations
and beliefs of their neighbors and
because you only see your immediate
neighborhood you have to somehow from
observation of the belief be able to
reason about what was the signal that
led to the belief that you're observing
and this inferential task seems to be
hard
and so this entangling the influence of
neighbors beliefs and their private
signals is not an easy task and there's
multiple behavioral experiments that
show that you know the way people
actually update their opinions is not in
groups is not consistent with what the
Bayesian view would suggest but what is
the computational aspect of this was not
fully studied as as far as I can tell
recently we actually were able to show
that even computing the one step of the
Bayesian posterior in the network
setting based on the observation of your
neighbor is is actually np-hard
basically if I give you a network and
then each have one private you know one
private signal and they form their
beliefs even if I start from a common
prior I have the belief of my neighbors
and I want to compute the Bayesian
posterior as if I had the observation of
any one in the in the network and you
can show in in certain case worst-case
scenarios that you can encode to
well-known hard problems in in to this
both the subset-sum problem and and the
exact cover and in one case as the
network grows we need the diversity of
the distribution of the signals to to
grow and in the other on the right side
what we need
is basically to have nodes in the
network whose degree girls with n we
believe these can be further relaxed if
we don't but you know our reduction was
was quite straightforward and simple
so yes it's probably Sharpie complete
it's probably Sharpie complete but we
were not able to show it actually that's
a very good point it's probably Sharpie
complete and it's probably a Sharpie
complete to even approximate I think but
you know but this is sort of as far as
we've gone sort of so far now so given
this hardness that you know behaviorally
this is hard computationally this is
hard so what have people been doing one
idea based on this the group model is
just to as we said repeatedly average
the priors with the values of the
neighbors but the problem with this is
that as you know we all know from basic
you know Markov chain theory or
non-negative matrix theory this ends up
being some weighted average of the
initial beliefs and the weights in this
way that average are the influence of
each node in in the network you can
think of them as the centrality of nodes
in the network so how much say you have
in pushing this weighted average has
nothing to do with what you know it's
basically how much of the network
traffic goes goes through you and the
problem with this is that this update
suffers from redundancy neglect right
you cannot remove the redundancy in in
the in the beliefs that are reported to
you because if three people report the
same thing to you you give it three
times the way not knowing that there
might have been a node two hops away
that gave the same information and so
and think about the Bayesian updating is
that it's precisely has a way of
removing this redundancy and the quote
the
shuh is that doing this in a distributed
way is hard so what we have been
thinking about in the past few years is
to try to merge these two views together
on the one side we want to allow for
arrival of new observations on the other
hand we want to inject some more
rationality into these models so we came
up with another heuristic that tries to
interpolate between the Bayesian and and
the de Groote model a few years ago
which was this idea that we can average
the beliefs with the private Bayesian
posterior in other words first assume
that you have no neighbors compute your
Bayesian posterior and then average the
result with the prior of your neighbors
and then we thought okay that we proved
a bunch of results for for for this
update and then we say well why just
average why can't I do something else
maybe I can also average the logs
instead of averaging the beliefs and we
were also able to show that in fact you
can read arrive this update in which you
average the logs of the beliefs of your
neighbors with your private Bayesian
posterior as a distributed algorithm for
solving the centralized inference
problem I'm sorry so the idea here is
that you want the log of the beliefs on
the wrong States to to go to negative
infinity right and they looked at the
cyclic yes yes yeah yes so there are all
these depending on what type of but they
look at the full Bayesian update in the
particular case where you can
characterize the full Bayesian case when
you have two states so in the cyclic
Network there are some symmetries that
you can explore that allows you
to do this but here we showed that okay
it's the log of the beliefs also under
certain conditions on the connectivity
of the network and and on the weights
works what what does work mean it means
that the belief on the wrong states will
go to zero exponentially fast and all
the belief gets concentrated on the
correct state and you reach consensus on
a belief that is degenerate and
concentrated on on the correct state
assuming that globally there's enough
information to learn the state so after
that we started thinking well what is so
special about these two specific updates
in the end I'm just throwing out all
these heuristic ways of doing things
without really understanding what's
going on what are the limits of these
type of updates and more precisely is
there a way for me to see how these
updates are removed from the fully
Bayesian setting right how can I relate
that fully Bayesian sitting to 2d set
about this so we decided to embed this
into a larger class of problems so that
hopefully at least in certain settings
also includes the fully Bayesian update
and that's what I want to talk about
when does this generalize setting
include the Bayesian update as a special
case and when it doesn't and what are
the consequences of that so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna define a family
of updates instead of trying to look at
a particular functional form we want to
leave this functional form open and try
to see from first principles we can read
arrive what this functional form should
be and so we say that the most general
thing that we can handle what would it
look like so you have some aggregation
rule or some social learning rule which
we call this fyt that could be
potentially time varying it could defer
for different agents and this social
learning rule takes a look at each nodes
belief and each neighbors H nodes
neighbors beliefs and it looks at the
entire history of that node and its
neighbors right and then by somehow
aggregating
believes it spits out a belief and then
with this interim belief that is the
result of this aggregation we run the
the single agent Bayesian update okay so
this fi T is a function that takes
beliefs of each node and its neighbors
for the entire T plus 1 seconds which is
the entire history
so what assumptions should this F
satisfy and this is what I want to
briefly talk about the full details are
in our in a somewhat long paper I'd be
happy to send it to you it's about to
appear hopefully soon so instead of
writing down the rules we write down a
set of desirable properties for these
rules the first desirable property is
what we call label neutrality the idea
here is that if I have this aggregation
of beliefs
does it matter really if I real able the
states and aggregate versus aggregating
and then relabeling okay so note that
this notation I use in here with the T
as the as the soup index encodes the
entire history over time so this is the
belief of myself and my neighbors for
all time and then I'm saying if I
permute the indices of the states if I
aggregate and then permute or if I
permute and then aggregate this should
not make a difference ok the second one
is one which is motivated by how the
Bayes rule actually works basically says
that if I condition my beliefs on a
subset of states and then aggregate I
should get the same answer as when I
aggregate and then condition another way
to say this is that if I care about the
belief on a subset of the states I
should only care about my neighbors
beliefs on those states and and nothing
more so this is what we call
independence of irrelevant alternatives
so I don't care about states that don't
matter to me if I condition and
aggregate
is the same as aggregating and then
conditioning so these are conditions
that at least in asta
yes sorry not necessarily no no because
I'm comparing it to its own rule so I'm
saying if I aggregate the states and
permute lis index or if I permute the
index and then aggregate I should get
the same answer the third one is
monotonicity with respect to the
immediate with respect to the previous
step it's hard to parse than the the
notation here in in a few minutes but
basically it says if I have to believe
profiles that pretty much agree on
everything and then one of the agents
was lower on a particular state and then
suddenly became higher I should take
that as a signal that that agent
observed an observation that increased
the belief on that so the aggregation
rule should sort of notice this and and
act accordingly so there needs to be a
monetary City with respect to the
immediate history and then finally this
is what we claim is our the main
basically deviation from bayesian
rationality were we state that the
aggregation rule should not depend on
the entire history but depend only on
the last thing that was reported if you
look at all these other heuristics they
all have the same setting whereas the
Bayes rule does not have this so this is
our main departure from rationality
we're basically saying that it really I
don't have enough processing power to
maintain the entire history of
everyone's belief on on everything and
at every time step I look at the last
thing that they reports to me as sort of
a sufficient statistic of what they know
so under these four axioms were able to
show that the only update that satisfies
these axioms is a log-linear update okay
that if I look at the log ratio of the
posterior beliefs is a weighted
combination a linear combination of the
log ratio of the prior beliefs and the
only update that satisfies these are
these axioms is this one okay so in
particular this means that our subject
to those axioms our belief rule is
precisely like this that we look at the
log ratio a weighted combination of the
log ratio of neighbors priors plus the
log ratio of the likelihoods and then
the next question is given these axioms
what's a property should these weights
satisfy for the beliefs to eventually
reach consensus on on the true state and
that here's where we see an interesting
connection to the literature on group
polarization in social psychology so
group polarization is tendency to make
decisions in groups that are more
extreme than initial inclinations this
is something that has been sort of
evidence in a in a few psychological
studies and there are two prevailing
explanations for this one is called
social comparison theory which roughly
speaking it states that when you have a
group of like-minded people you want to
be like the rest of the group but you
want to distinguish yourself so you
compare yourself to the rest of the
group you tilt your opinions in it in
the extreme direction to stand out okay
the other explanation for this is what
is called the information influence
which basically states that you have
some reasons for believing what you
believe when you get into the room with
a group of like-minded people
and then you hear other independent
arguments for the same beliefs things
that you did not consider before and
they become further evidence for your
beliefs so your beliefs in what that
direction that you are going
strengthened further so these are the
two sort of prevailing explanations for
Group polarization there's been some
experimental studies sort of verifying
this if you have two groups one is
prejudice one is not after the
discussion you see the shifting of of
the sort of the the beliefs to to sort
of the more extreme direction so in in
our setting what this amounts to in the
sort of the log-linear setting is to
have basically the spectral radius of
the weights that define that network to
be greater than one we call that the
social learning rule group polarizing if
the spectral radius is less than one we
call it depolarizing and if it's equal
to one we call it non polarizing and we
showed that if you know you satisfy the
axioms that your network is strongly
connected you converge if and only if
the group's the opinions are non
polarizing and the idea is the following
the beliefs somehow convey information
that are buried in private observations
okay in the end what you'd like to do to
learn is to aggregate all the private
observations that you don't have direct
access to if you weigh them too much you
will spread misinformation if you weigh
them too little you will attenuate
possibly good information and the only
way that you can get allow this weight
to for things to get carried out so that
law of large numbers can kick in is for
the spectral radius to be equal to one
and a sufficient condition for that is
for the weights to add up to one so if
you pick the induce infinity norm of the
matrix to be one then that's a
sufficient condition for spectral radius
to be one of course you can have the
spectral radius be one but some weights
some rows add up to greater than one and
some rows
add up to less than one now the question
is what happens if I allow for the
weights to change if I allow for the
weights to change
assuming that eventually the rule is
unanimous and what that means is
equivalent to having respect the row
sums be equal to one meaning that if all
the consensus is a fixed point of this
update then you can actually prove that
learning happens even when the weights
decay as time goes to infinity so it's
standard in sort of the consensus
literature which doesn't have the
Bayesian part of this update to assume
that when the weights are positive
they're uniformly greater than some
minimum weight Epsilon we didn't want to
make that assumption because we felt
like you know over time you might
attenuate the influence of some members
in the social clique so we derive
conditions under which even as the
weights change without having a uniform
lower bound you could still have
basically convergence different senses
now let me just say I described these
axioms I mentioned that Bayesian
satisfies three out of the four but does
it doesn't always satisfy the three out
of the four and that's exactly the the
cases in which it doesn't satisfy some
of those axioms is where you get the
difficulty in the Bayesian updating so
if you have the settings like this where
there are multiple independent paths
then you can't write down the the
Bayesian update in closed form if you
exclude the updates of this form the
settings of this forum then you can
actually explicitly write down what the
Bayesian looks like and it's exactly
like the update we had except now it has
more memory because now you have to
include the entire history to be able to
remove the redundancy in data not only
that the weights actually have a very
nice combinatorial interpretation they
are Mobius inversion coefficients
the same ones that are used in you know
inclusion/exclusion formulas because in
the end all you're doing is you're
trying to remove the redundancy you're
basically saying which ones are
redundant and so I have to remove so in
this case in this picture here if I have
an edge from two to six then I can write
the update this way but if I don't have
the edge from two to six there is no way
for agent six to remove the double
counting of the log belief ratio of
agent two so no matter what agent twos
beliefs will be double counted in in
this setting do I have another minute
let me so these are the some examples of
networks that for which the Bayes rule
can be explicitly characterized we've
generalized this result to the case
where the update is not log linear but
has some general positive homogeneous
non-linear function basically we show
that they when this update is positive
homogeneous if it's of degree greater
than 1 then agents must learn with
positive probability if it's less than 1
then agents remain uncertain forever so
it has to be homogeneous of degree 1 and
not only that the curvature of that
update has to be bounded and these are
tight conditions so we have if you take
the logarithm of the of the rule and you
take the second derivative of the log
and normalized by the first derivative
this has to be bounded between minus 1
and 1 and this is a tight result meaning
that if the update is outside that the
update will not result in learning so
let me
we had some results on the rates for
this let me just put the conclusion
slide we developed a general family of
non Bayesian models describe the
connection to Bayesian ones derived them
from the axioms showed that Bayesian
learning is in general is hard and we
have some sufficient conditions on
network structures under which the
Bayesian learning derives directly from
axiom
and and we're running some experiments
right now to see if we can test some of
these let me stop here thank you so this
update actually as long as no one puts
zero belief on truth know I'm exposed so
if so if everyone puts zero belief on
what ends up being the true state then
obviously the the linear one doesn't
work the log-linear one what would would
still work but the linear one doesn't
know this update is not rational because
we said the rational one is hard we're
saying yeah we can I you know there's a
the update is not rational in the way
that you include other people's beliefs
because you're not removing redundancy
in those in those beliefs which one
yes yes so so some of these that's a
very good point so you can think of
actions at least in the binary setting
as quantized beliefs we have some
results on actions as well and I believe
the hardness result is actually more on
the action case then than the belief
case but the explicit form no we don't
have that in certain graphs we do yeah
yes
[Applause]